Speaker 1: Let's go now to Ron DeSantis.
When we say the Republican primary of 2024,
Ron DeSantis isn't actually in that primary
at this point in time. He may announce he
may not. One of the problems Ron DeSantis is
having is his personality. And Trump posted
to Truth Social the other day, said that that
DeSantis needs a personality transplant. And he
does. And here is an example. Clearly,
DeSantis has been advised by someone,
I guess you've got to be more bubbly or whatever.
He sounds ridiculous and it's so obviously
contrived. He's like pretending to be bubbly now.
This is DeSantis over the weekend at the Feenstra
family picnic in Iowa. This new DeSantis is
not particularly credible, but many maybe
some people will like the new bubbly DeSantis.
Speaker 3: You know, sometimes people will say to
me, they'll be like, Governor, why aren't other
Republicans doing what you're doing in Florida?
And I say, they are doing it. And they say, where?
I say they're doing it in Iowa. And in fact.
Speaker 1: This whiny voice,
by the way, is really tough.
Speaker 3: I was here in March and someone
kind of took note and they're like, Man,
look, all the stuff I was doing, Iowa was
like the Florida of the Midwest. They said.
Speaker 1: Are you guys following us?
Speaker 3: I want to let you know,
after watching all the good stuff you've
done in Iowa, it may be that Florida
is the Iowa the Southeast. So we'll see.
Speaker 1: There you go. Wow. And you bubbly
DeSantis with a new personality. Maybe that's
going to. He told the people. He then went to,
I guess, a diner or a restaurant of some kind
with Mike Pence. And if you want if you want a
list of people not to take personality modeling
from, I would put my Mike Pence at the top of
that list. And here they sit down for some kind of
meal. Who knows if it's real or fake or whatever.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: You know,
they're going to shock. Yeah.
Speaker 1: And as you can see,
Ron DeSantis sitting very, very strongly.
Speaker 3: All right. Right.
Speaker 1:
All right. Unclear whether anybody ordered
any food or what the deal with that was. And
then we'll just go now to the closing of Ron
Desantis's little speech there at the Feenstra
family picnic. And he tries to energize the crowd
with one of these crescendos, but it only sort of
works. The crowd seems to understand this is
like a crescendo finish. So they do play along
and clap, but it all feels very, very forced.
Speaker 3: It occurred to me that you can have
the best Declaration of Independence in the world.
You could have the best constitution in the world.
But if you don't have people that are willing
throughout throughout our history to stand up,
put on that uniform, risk their lives and in many
instances give that last full measure of devotion,
then it is going to amount to very much. And
so we are not called upon to make sacrifices
of that magnitude, but we're also called upon to
do battle in the political arena. So what I say
to you as Republicans put on the full armor of
God. Take your stand. Stand firm for truth. We
must fight the good fight. We must finish the race
and we must keep the faith. I can tell you this.
I am proud of what we've done in Florida.
Speaker 1: Inspiring an electric speech,
as you can see.
Speaker 3: I'm thankful where Governor
Reynolds and the team have done in Iowa. But I've
only begun to fight. Thank you all. God bless you.
It's so great to be in Iowa. Thank you so much.
Unidentified: Thank you. God bless
y'all.
Speaker 1:
It all feels so empty. It feels vapid. It feels
ridiculous. And yet it's like a pantomime of a
real campaign with a real candidate. Now, he may
declare, and it may become a real campaign. And
I guess to some degree, that will make him a real
candidate. The numbers look very bad for DeSantis.
I want someone to run against Trump. I want
someone to credibly do it. The numbers just don't
seem to be falling. And DeSantis is favored. So
we'll see what decision he ultimately makes. And
he has to make that decision soon, I think within
the next 4 to 6 weeks or that's going to do it.